yippie kai movie lovers i'm jan
and today i'm revealing 36 devilish
details you missed in lucifer's season 5
from crazy easter eggs to hilarious meta
references and ingenious production
design
spoiler alert it is gonna be epic the
third episode of season five
is perhaps one of the funniest in the
series so far as lucifer and chloe
investigate a murder on the set of
diablo a network tv procedural show
that's an hilariously ott version of
lucifer
some of the jokes are more obvious riffs
on the characters we know and love
like i keep telling you detective doofus
a reference to lucifer's detective
douche nickname for dan
but others are more subtle such as the
show's billboard with diablo's name in
neon lights just like the original
season one lucifer poster and then
there's diablo's version of lucifer's
mojo power you want to find the killer
figure out they're yearning isn't there
a better word for that although lucy
evidently doesn't like the word yearn
he did actually say it himself in season
one when he used his mojo against a
corrupt
lapd detective what do you yearn for in
that rotten soul of yours
when ella finds the murder weapon that
killed diablo she calls it the only
blade that can kill the devil
this is actually a sneaky reference to
asriel's blade which featured heavily in
the season 2 episode trip to stabby town
where it got close to killing lucifer
when dam wielded it in anger against him
in episode 2 chloe can see michael isn't
really acting like lucifer normally
would and she tries to get him to do
something typically inappropriate by
giving him dan's dessert to eat is that
my pudding yes here you go daniel
okay what's your game spitting it
he's spinning it the issue of lucifer
pinching his pudding has been a
recurring joke throughout the series
ever since
lucy stole it in season two i know you
ate my pudding
and another time dan even discovered
that lucy's mum charlotte was also
stealing his pudding
in fact there was a whole episode in
season three devoted to a crime that
occurred at the dessert factory
pudding plus is my favorite okay twice
as much protein as all the other brands
but poor dan never really gets a break
because when the real lucifer returns
from hell in season five
he starts using dan's mug for his
whiskey drinking at the police precinct
the noir episode is a lot of fun with
loads of easter eggs and references
hidden in the background when lucifer
and p.i jack monroe go to visit willy
the sausage prince they find him getting
his portrait painted while ridiculously
dressed as a knight
and if you take a closer look on the
walls there are lots more portraits of
willy who clearly sees and models
himself
after old european royalty because
there's a portrait of him in the exact
same style as a famous painting of
england's king henry viii
and there's another portrait of him that
looks very much like the style of this
painting of the french king francis the
first
then there's a nightclub where lily rose
aka lilith sings which is appropriately
named the garden club because lilith
originally lived with adam in the garden
of eden and kept a piece of the garden
in her ring
and her flowery name in the show lily
rose is another nice nod to her garden
of eden origins
inside the club behind the bar is al
capone's machine gun with a plaque that
reads
thanks for listening of course customers
sometimes
pour their problems out to bartenders
who have a reputation as sympathetic
listeners so it's no coincidence that
linda who's a therapist in the modern
day world of lucifer turns out to be the
bartender
at the club al capone frequented but
there's an extra layer to this reference
because the noir episode is set in 1946
which is the same year that the
real-life capone was examined by a
psychiatrist who declared that the
mobster had the mentality of a 12
year old child oh and when the bartender
pours lucifer a drink we get another
little shout out to actress rachel
harris's usual role in the show and how
lucifer normally addresses her as doctor
when lucy says oh lovely that's what the
doctor ordered in episode two
just before chloe reveals to michael
that she knows who he really
is she shows him the bullet necklace
luther gave her in season three
it's the bullet from when you shot me
remember in the warehouse early in our
partnership chloe's showing the bullets
to michael just before she shoots him in
the leg exactly like she did to lucifer
in season one
is a delicious detail that proves
michael can't fool her
once i shot lucifer to prove he was the
devil and now i'm shooting you to prove
you're not
interestingly michael betrayed himself
and his reaction when chloe showed him
the necklace because if you re-watch the
moment there's a slight flicker of
hesitation when she mentions it
see still have it on
i can see that and on top of that
because michael doesn't know what the
bullet necklace is he also doesn't
realize that chloe's technically lying
when she says that she still has it on
because she actually took the necklace
off towards the end of season three when
she got together with pierce
and didn't wear it at all in season four
after lucifer and chloe sleep together
for the first time he asks her whether
she feels cold making a joke about how
in the first season chloe was adamant
she'd never have sex with him
i will never ever ever
sleep with you never playing hard to get
a like when hell freezing something
and notice that when chloe arrives at
lucy's place that night she's dressed in
red a color of passion and love of
course but also a color closely
associated with the devil
in the show lucifer often wears a little
red pocket squire and the soles of his
shoes are also coloured red
and we saw only last season how the
show's costume department played on that
colour association in eve's clothes
which went from being heavenly white to
various shades of red
after she reconnected with lucifer the
morning after when chloe wakes up she
asks lucy if she was snoring like a
truck driver
she doesn't let him reply but the
moment's a nice call back to season one
when she woke up in lucifer's bed after
getting drunk the night before
that time nothing actually happened
between them but as she leaves
lucifer tells her you snore by the way
like an albanian field wench
another funny season five moment comes
when maze decides to style herself
exactly like ella in an effort to try
and be nicer and learn how to become
more emotionally available as dr linda
suggested oh my god i have that exact
same shirt
yes you did wait do you steal my clothes
maize doesn't just get ella's look down
to a t
she also hilariously tries to imitate
ella's mannerisms
and that moment reminds me of other such
humorous times on the show including
season two when lucifer decided to learn
how to douche
and dressed up and tried to be like dan
where to now twinsie
and then there was a time in season 4
the eve dressed up as chloe and also
copied her body language to try and get
lucifer's attention
in season 5 ella almost seems to find
her geeky soulmate in pete when he turns
up with tickets for a star trek
convention and they both start having a
conversation in klingon
a funny little call back to when ella
tried to talk to chloe in the fictional
language in season two
it's klingon for the king is trapped in
star trek they play three-dimensional
chess
and there's an even geekier detail in
the clothes ella wears to the convention
her uniform is blue which is the color
worn by science and medical personnel in
star trek and that fits our ella
perfectly as she's a forensic scientist
when michael strides into the middle of
a shootout between chloe and a bunch of
bad guys he whistles the theme to the
show
[Music]
which chloe immediately recognizes
because this isn't the first time that
tune is featured in an episode
yes back during a case involving a
murdered musician in season two
lucifer wrote a song for chloe that
perfectly sums up both his role in their
partnership and the show's premise
crime solving devil it makes sense
don't overthink it intriguingly the plot
of that season 2 episode also involved
lucifer returning to la out of the blue
after having spent time in hell to save
chloe a situation which nicely mirrors
the circumstances in season 5. though
this time it's michael pretending to be
lucifer who returns
there must be some big stanley kubrick
fans among the lucifer crew
as season 5 has visual shout shoutouts
to not one but two of the iconic
filmmakers movies
in episode 2 chloe's investigation into
murderous goings-on in a tech
billionaire space simulation
provides the perfect opportunity for a
tribute to 2001 a space odyssey
the story kicks off with a call back to
the film's spaceship and its sleek
monochrome design and the image of an
astronaut making their way up an
octagonal walkway
the next kubrick reference pops up in
episode 7
when chloe and lucifer head to the home
of a man they believed to be a serial
killer
some shining esque music plays in the
background as a little boy pedals down a
corridor on a tricycle
well that burns well just as danny
torrance rode around the corridors of
the overlook hotel in the shining
and the wallpaper in the apartment block
corridor also has vibes of the shining
hotels carpet about it
with its geometric pattern and orange
and brown colouring
when lilith is explaining to lucifer the
history of her ring she talks about how
the aztecs threw her into a volcano
i survive and somebody writes it on a
stone tablet you know how these things
start
i do her comment about stone tablets is
a reference to the ten commandments that
god gave to moses which were inscribed
on two tablets of stone and which formed
the basis of many of the rules in
judaism and christianity
in the finale michael delights in
preying on a menadiel's fears for his
son charlie
really tapping into his anxiety about
his baby's ill health growing up and
even his mortality
as michael badges a men a deal about all
this and lucifer joins in arguing
against michael
we see the twins position themselves on
either side of their brother creating an
image of a literal devil and angel on
the mendadeal's shoulders
they grow up so fast listen to him
brother don't let him get inside your
head
the interesting thing here is that the
devil lucifer is the one appealing to a
menadiel's better nature while the angel
michael is the one
trying to make him indulge his worst
instincts often in this angel and devil
on the shoulder trope the devil appears
on the protagonist's left side
as that's associated with evil while the
angel appears on their right side
however here lucifer the devil is on a
menadiel's right while michael the angel
is on a menadiel's left free enforcing
the fact that lucifer and michael act
contrary to their prescribed roles this
scene also reminds me of a similar
moment in season four
who's the first stop lucifer do it
when the kill is revealed in episode six
during a dj set at looks it turns out to
be a jealous ex-husband
and as he explains why he did it green
lights swirl around him and there's even
a shot that makes it look as if they're
radiating from his head
of all the colours they could have
chosen to light this scene and frame the
killer's head
green is the perfect one as it's long
been associated with jealousy and envy
the crucial moment at the very end of
the penultimate episode sees dan arrive
with a gun and proceed to shoot lucifer
right in front of chloe
but those with a keen ear might have
noticed something familiar about the
soundtrack playing in the lead
up to that moment yes if you're a fan of
the critically acclaimed netflix series
dark you might have recognized the song
playing in the background
as inside which played in the third and
final season of that series
the lyrics of the song which plays
subtly in the background perfectly rack
up the tension and enhance the dramatic
build-up to dan pulling the trigger on
lucifer
as his show lucifer has always enjoyed
making meta references
sounds like a soon to be cancelled tv
show but in season five there are so
many that i'll list some of the best
here
after ella discovers that chloe and
lucifer have finally had sex
she explains her reaction in the same
way that many of the fandom's deca
starshippers may well have felt before
that moment
i was so ready to have my decker star
dreams crushed again why because it's
been one bummer after another with you
two i didn't want to get my hopes up and
the tagline of the diablo tv show is
don't tell him the devil made you do it
which is a reference back to lucifer's
complaints earlier in the series about
humans trying to pin the blame for their
sins on him all the time
well the devil made me do it i have
never made any one of them do
anything which is why it's particularly
funny when ella quotes the tagline back
at lucifer
don't tell him the devil made you do it
and there's the moment when lucifer
comments about the actor who plays
diablo and the script notes he made
about his character
got a fascinating insight into the
character some wild
theories about self-loathing but we
can't get it all right this is of course
a joke about lucifer and how his own
self-hatred and sense of guilt came to a
head in season
4 causing him to transform into his full
devil form
although lucy eventually recognized his
self-hatred back then
why do i hate myself so much now that
reference seems to have flown completely
over his head
in the noir episode down the alleyway
outside the garden club there's a sign
for the alibi room
a little in joke for fans of procedural
shows like lucifer
a few other meta details are that carnal
girl 506 one of jed's jilted lovers
appears in episode 506 of the series
and in episode 507 the fake whisper
killer lives in unit
507 also linda's daughter
adriana nassar is named after netflix
originals manager
as you can see season 5 of lucifer is
really packing in the callbacks to
previous seasons so it's well worth
making time for an epic binge rewatch
but as much as we love our streaming
services it can be really frustrating to
find the tv show you want to watch all
the latest seasons of it
aren't available in your country however
thanks to the sponsor of this video
nordvpn you can make these kind of
geo-restrictions a thing of the past
a vpn or virtual private network helps
you bypass
jio restrictions or censorship on
content not available to view in your
country
nordvpn can help you connect to many
streaming services
just pick a server in another location
and browse the internet as if you were
there
one thing we like about nord is a
superfast download speeds on its 5
000 plus servers through the use of new
generation vpn technologies like
wireguard
and unlike many free and slower vpns
nord has a no log policy meaning it
doesn't record or retain details of your
online activity when you're connected to
its service
plus you can connect up to six devices
at the same time
including your laptop tablet desktop
phone and home router
so you can cover all of your connected
devices for a limited time
nordvpn are offering all our viewers 68
off the two-year plan and a bonus month
absolutely free
it works out at just 3.71 a month to
secure your online privacy
and you get an additional month for free
just visit nordvpn.comflix or tap the
link in the video description to access
the offer
so what was your favorite moment in
season 5 and did you spot any other
easter eggs or cool details
leave your thoughts in the comments
below tap left to watch my full luce of
a playlist
including part one ending explained and
part two in season six series
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this a
thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers